(Musique)
Ouvrez votre cœur aux cadeaux incroyables que la civilisation
nous offre.
Vous appuyez sur un interrupteur et il y a de la lumière électrique.
Vous ouvrez un robinet et il y a de l'eau chaude et de l'eau froide,
et de l'eau potable.
C'est un cadeau que des millions de gens dans le monde
ne connaîtront jamais.
Ce ne sont que quelques-uns des innombrables cadeaux
auxquels nous pouvons ouvrir nos cœurs.
Je vous souhaite donc d'ouvrir votre cœur
à toutes ces bénédictions, et de les laisser couler à travers vous.
Et tous ceux que vous rencontrerez aujourd'hui
seront bénis par vous,
rien que par vos yeux,
par votre sourire,
par votre toucher,
rien que par votre présence.
Laissez la reconnaissance déborder
dans une bénédiction tout autour de vous.
Alors, ce sera vraiment une bonne journée. » (Musique)
(Applaudissements)
Louie Schwartzberg : Merci.
Merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)